[Applause]
wow
i haven't met some of these people
before
conan o'brien had everyone at the emmys
wondering what's going on here and now
we know i said why don't you
i said why don't you come on stage with
us we win
and he goes really and i said yeah
here's what went down and the emmy for
variety special live
goes to
stephen colbert's election night 2020.
stephen colbert got his name called at
the 73rd primetime emmy awards but all
eyes went to another talk show host who
followed him through the audience toward
the stage
yep that's steven hugging conan on stage
interesting because last time we checked
the harvard grad wasn't part of the late
show writing staff wow
i haven't met some of these people
before
and for a moment there it kind of seemed
like steven was just as curious about
o'brien's presence on stage and these
people behind me are absolutely
most of the people behind me
most of the people behind me really
deserve
this emmy right now
thank you very much
but don't worry steven gave all the
details to e.t later in the press room
basically it was actually his idea to
have conan join him on stage
oh hello so many congrats to all of you
the the content that you have brought us
this last year has just been
unparalleled i i am surprised to see
though that conan o'brien is not here
whose idea was it to bring him on stage
how did he get up there behind you uh
conan would be here but i had to fire
him in the last five minutes
it was just we were just we just it was
a budgetary thing you know
kobits hit a lot of budgets really hard
we had to cut they said cut by height
so very lucky to del monte
very lucky del monte but conan joined
the show just for a few minutes there
it's been an honor to work with him i'm
sure he'll find i'm sure he'll find a
gig out there someplace
really though how did he get up on stage
i said why don't you
i said why don't you come on stage with
us we win
and he goes really and i said yeah and
he goes okay if you change your mind let
me know and it just came up
we love conan we're honored to be uh of
super fans of conan o'brien but colbert
wasn't the only emmy winner on team coco
i think like many of us in this room i
was kind of rooting for conan so this is
bittersweet fellow late night host john
oliver took a moment in one of his two
speeches to give conan his flowers thank
you so much conan for 30 years of
inspiring comedy writers
a ridiculous number you're the best
um
thank you